I was in eighth grade we came home one  time front door was locked but then our  kitchen door was wedged open with a  slipper  and we found all the stuff stolen there  was a box of donuts that we had that we  bought from the store that was sealed  and it was I don't know actually but it  was it was ripped open and there was a  bunch of donuts taken out and it was a  fresh box so we were like okay Intimates  and go in the bathroom in my bathroom  some dude took a [ __ ]  in the bathroom no toilet paper didn't  flush left a [ __ ] log the house was a  mess it's like it's [ __ ] Donuts  raspberries  [Music]  he's gotta be there's gotta be trick  Donuts man well they had time that's  just something he took a [ __ ] in your  bed  this will be hilarious [ __ ] drop the  deuce and then that was it does it feel  like invasion of Pride oh yeah that was  the second time that's happened too